hello and welcome to episode 30 of the
michaela peterson podcast
in this episode i spoke with dr natasha
campbell mcbride
author of gut and psychology syndrome
creator of the gaps
diet dr natasha campbell mcbride has a
degree in medicine and postgraduate
degrees in both neurology and human
nutrition
in her clinic in cambridge she
specializes in nutrition for children
and adults with behavioral and learning
disabilities
and adults with digestive and immune
system disorders
the gaps diet basically starts off like
the carnivore diet
and it's a dietary treatment that's
quite successful
even though not widely accepted by
mainstream medicine
something we discuss in this episode i
wanted to speak with dr natasha because
her way of treating health starting with
the gut
began decades ago before the carnivore
diet was known at all
she's absolutely brilliant one thing we
may disagree on or i haven't decided
completely
she adds in a certain type of raw milk
to help heal the gut
let me know what you guys think of that
if you would if you tried it
i think the connection between dairy and
inflammatory conditions is fairly solid
at least it was for me however not all
dairy is equal which is something we
discussed
in this episode we also delve into foods
in the gaps diet
her opinions on mainstream medicine the
microbiome
and her opinion on north american cows
which was hilarious to be honest
this is a russian lady that is very
russian very smart and
really knows her stuff this episode is
brought to you by
smidge if you've been on a carnivore
diet or a low carb diet
or you're planning on switching from a
high carb or standard american diet to a
low carb diet
sometimes people have trouble with
digesting fats
particularly near the beginning of
dietary switches sometimes those
troubles can last longer too
smidge makes an enzyme to help with
protein and fat digestion
hcl plus enzymes it's the only digestive
supplement that combines a gentle dose
of hydrochloric acid
with pepsin for helping digesting
protein
plus three types of lipase to break down
fats and other enzymes to help process
gluten
casein and other proteins although just
don't eat gluten
the supplement is great for ancestral
diets those with mild acid reflux which
is commonly due to
low stomach acid which hcl can help with
bloating or if you want to maximize the
body's absorption of nutrients are
concerned with fat digestion
in particular at the beginning of
dietary changes smidge makes supplements
using the cleanest formulas and
ingredients they're non-gmo with no
additives or common allergens
you can get hcl plus enzymes at
smidge.com
that's s-m-i-d-g-e
thanks for sponsoring this episode hope
you guys enjoy it
[Music]
hello it's really nice to meet you hello
hello nice to meet you
now welcome to my podcast thank you
uh thank you so much for joining me i i
read
a lot of your work in i think it was
2016 when i first started to
try and get my autoimmune disorder under
control
and i was eliminating foods left right
and center without any idea
of what to do really and i came across
your book about a year
into my diet and i think it aligns
it aligned shockingly well with what i
had already
figured out just trying to treat myself
so i wanted to introduce you
to my audience because i think the work
you've done is
incredibly important thank you what what
energy did you have uh juvenile
rheumatoid arthritis it was later
rediagnosed as juvenile idiopathic
arthritis but it was
severe i had my hip and ankle replaced
when i was 17.
so yes it was tough but i thought what
we should do we should just get started
if you could give a bit of a brief
background to my audience about who you
are and what it is you do
hello my name is natasha campbell
mcbride i'm the creator of a concept of
gaps
gutten psychology syndrome and gut and
physiology syndrome
the concept of gaps established a
certain connection
between the functioning of the digestive
system in the person
and the functioning of the rest of the
body hippocrates all those thousands of
years ago
the father of modern medicine hypocrites
made a statement that all
diseases began in the dead and the more
we learned with our modern scientific
tools then we realized just how correct
he was
my first gaps book got in psychology
syndrome focused on the
function of the brain on all the
problems that we can help with that
function
learning disabilities in children and
adults in mental illness
i've just completed the second gaps book
got in physiology syndrome
which will come out this autumn and this
year
which focuses on the rest of the body
and it completes the gaps concept gaps
concept has become a global phenomenon
from the from the time when the first
book came out the first book has been
translated into 20 languages and there
are more translations coming in
and the millions of people around the
world are using this protocol
for healing from chronic degenerative
diseases
yeah okay so when when did your first
book come out
2004 and the second edition came out in
2010
okay so i found about out about the gaps
diet i think in 2016 like i said
but you're one of the first people who
were
you know kind of before the whole paleo
diet became
of something people do or the keto diet
or
right now what i'm on is called the
carnivore diet and you were
way before all that and i think you have
elements of each of those diets in your
protocol so
could you give a bit of a background
about
what you do in order to heal the gut and
that's what you believe
is the cause of most illnesses
i don't just believe it i know it
because this
is all my clinical experience with
thousands of patients and the clinical
experience of thousands of other
holistic doctors um confirmed
the fact that all diseases begin in the
gut all of them
so what is gaps what do we have in the
gaps person
we have an epidemic of gaps particularly
in the western world
and as mother and father pass their gut
flora to the child at the moment of
birth
this epidemic is getting deeper with
every generation
we have a person with abnormal gut flora
gut fluid is that mass of microbes
that live inside your digestive system
and it's a
in a healthy situation a highly balanced
microbial community
there's all kinds of creatures in there
living in harmony with each other
they'll plant each other eat each other
control each other don't allow any one
of them to get out of control
and as a balanced community as a
harmonious community
all of these microbes work very well
together and they serve our body very
very well
problem is we humans are very good at
creating imbalances
in nature human body is a part of nature
every time you take antibiotics you kill
off bacteria
only bacteria these bacteria were
controlling fungi viruses protozoa
care worms flukes and all kinds of other
creatures
that live in that harmonious community
inside your body
once you've knocked out the bacteria all
these other creatures
suddenly become uncontrolled they
overgrow
the whole balance is gone and all the
creatures
which were beneficial for us as part of
a harmonious balanced community
when out of control when overgrowing
become passages
because there are no such thing as a
good microbe or a bad microbe
all microbes can cause disease every one
of them
it's the balance it's the overall
diversity and the balance in the
microbial community that makes
every microbe do only good things for
you
but every microbial it gets out of
control can cause disease and can cause
disorder
and that's what happens in gaps people
and as i said the mother and the father
passed their god flourish with each
child at the moment of birth
we have now generations of people with
damaged gut flora
and with every generation it becomes
worse and worse
because for example if grandparents had
maybe one or two causes of antibiotics
which came out on the market in 1950s or
60s
slightly damaged their gut floor and
then they passed that slightly damaged
gut floor to their children
but then their children grew up in a
very different world
very different to the world where their
parents grew up in
they grew up in a world where
antibiotics were given to them for every
cough and sneeze
where agricultural industry appeared on
the planet which is using increasing
numbers of
agricultural chemicals most of which are
antibiotics in their nature
they don't just kill bacteria they kill
all kinds of microbes they destroy
all kinds of microbes at the same time
food industry appeared on the planet
which destroys food and turns it into
concoctions chemical concoctions which
pollute human bodies don't feed them
very well
and feed pathogenic microbes cause
complete havoc
in the human body and then they grew up
in a generations where
girls were given contraceptive pill from
a very young age
they took that pill for quite a few
years before they're ready to start
their family
the pill has a devastating effect on the
immune system of the woman
hormonal system and on her microbiome
on her microbial community and her body
because we have my brother community not
only in the gut we have microbes
everywhere
in the human body they live in your
lungs in your heart in your blood in
your
abdominal cavity in your brain in your
eyes
they're everywhere and they're all
supposed to be balanced
it has to be a diverse balanced
community when we take chemicals
which destroy some portion of that
microbial community
they absorb into your bloodstream and
damage the microbial community
everywhere in your body so coming back
to those generations of young people who
went through their
childhood and young years exposed to
many many uh
man-made chemicals which are
increasingly becoming became unknown
on the planet and so by the time they
decided to have their first child
their floor is far more damaged than
what they got from their parents becomes
far more damaged
and that is what they pass to their
children at the moment of birth
and with every generation now this
situation is accelerating
it's becoming more and more severe the
child is born
already with the gaps regarding
psychology and physiology syndrome with
abnormal
microbial community in the podium when a
person's digestive system is dominated
by abnormal
flora abnormal microbial community you
do not digest your food well
you can be eating the best quality food
in the world but your digestive system
is unable to break it down properly and
absorb it properly
so you develop multiple nutritional
deficiencies
majority of that food is converted by
the pathogenic microbial community into
a whole
river of poisonous chemicals
at the same time these microbes damage
the integrity of your gut wall it
becomes porous and leaky
it becomes like a sieve and all these
chemicals absorb
into your bloodstream the foods don't
get the chance to be digested properly
before they absorb through that damaged
leaky gut wall
you start absorbing everything
undigested
then the immune system finds these
undigested foods in your blood in your
lymph
looks at them doesn't recognize them as
food and attacks them
and this attack can manifest itself as
any symptom under the sun in any organ
and these symptoms can be immediate or
delayed
so on any given day the person has no
idea what they reacting to
you might be reacting to a piece of lamb
you just had for lunch plus a tomato you
had yesterday plus
eggs you had two days ago plus something
else you had two weeks ago
in reality you're reacting to everything
you eat because most of your foods
do not have a chance to be digested
properly before they absorb
so what happens in a gas person as a
summary
instead of being a source of nourishment
for you your digestive system becomes a
major
source of toxicity a river of undigested
foods
poisonous chemicals alive microbes
immune complexes and all sorts of other
damaging things
flow from the gut into your blood into
your lymph
get distributed around the body or
wherever this toxic flow gets to it will
cause disease
and of course the immune system has to
join in because your immune system is
its very existence
is to deal with uh damage to you
to deal with invaders in your body this
is an invader coming in from your
digestive system
so your immune system will find tissues
in your body which are contaminated by
this toxic river coming from the gut
if it is your knee your joint let's say
your knee that's where
some of this toxicity has accumulated
and many of these toxins like to attach
themselves to proteins
they fit in nicely with proteins they
attach themselves to
particularly sulfur-containing amino
acids in the protein
and collagen three quarters of all uh
protein in the human body is collagen
this is an elastic protein that holds
our bodies together
it is particularly richly represented in
your joints
in your ligaments in your bones in your
muscles
and in other parts of your connective
tissue in the body
collagen unfortunately is a magnet for
toxicity
many toxins coming out of the gut attach
themselves to molecules of collagen
so let's say your knee largely made out
of collagen
this toxicity came in attached itself to
collagen molecules
and they changed those molecules
three-dimensional structure
so your immune system then finds this
changed collagen molecules
it sees that this is abnormal this is a
foreign abnormal
protein so the first thing that the
immune system would do it would launch
an immediate
response of the shelf response that is
not specific but it's immediate it's
right there it's ready
inflammation what is inflammation
your knee is swollen red hot painful
and the function is limited inflammation
is very effective at cleaning up
contaminated tissues in the human body
so if this bunch of toxins came once
and then stopped inflammation will do
the job very nicely your knee might be
swollen for a few days
and then it subsides the knee is left
clean
the immune system has cleaned it up
repaired it everything's fine
we can forget about that episode but if
toxicity hasn't stopped coming
if your situation is chronic and the gut
wall is leaky
and the food continues absorbing and
digested and the river of toxicity keeps
flowing
for months and months or years most of
your life
then inflammation is not enough then the
immune system will use
its other mechanism called autoimmunity
where it will
learn about this contaminated collagen
in your knees
memorize that information and start
creating specific
antibodies specific cells against
those contaminated molecules of collagen
so your immune system will start
destroying your knee
destroying those damaged contaminated
molecules
our mainstream medicine considers
autoimmunity to be a misguided behavior
of our immune system
they still believe that the immune
system doesn't know what it's doing and
it's mistakenly
attacking your own dishes no
that's not the truth your immune system
is never misguided
it always knows what it's doing and it
produces all kinds of mechanisms that it
has in its toolbox
all kinds of tools it has in its toolbox
to deal
with the situation in your body and it
knows what's appropriate for what
situation
so antibodies are important
unfortunately as soon as
your immune system developed antibodies
against contaminated collagen
it's not attacking clean collagen
healthy collagen is your knees
why would the immune system do such a
thing it will never do such a thing
what it's doing your collagen is
contaminates it
so autoimmune disease should be renamed
it should be made the contamination
disease
not autoimmune disease because
autoimmune means implies that
the immune system is attacking itself
attacking you
so based on that belief and based on
that misunderstanding
our mainstream medicine has been busily
suppressing people's immune systems with
steroids
and other terrible drugs and
they just beat the immune system down to
stop it attacking your own body
so as a result nobody is dealing with
that contamination
it continues in your body the disease
progresses
but what happens with these drugs the
symptoms
of your disorder the red hot
and swollen and painful and limitational
function
all those symptoms were caused by the
immune system immune system that was
cleaning up your knee
dealing with the contamination yeah as
you beat the immune system down with
powerful drugs
with steroids destroy the immune system
the symptoms disappear because nobody's
reacting nobody's dealing with the
situation
did that stop the disease no the disease
will continue destroying your knee
the pre it will progress even faster now
but with nobody protecting you from it
and nobody cleaning up your knee and
nobody dealing with that situation in
your body anymore
our mainstream medicine has been acted
for decades uh the complete failure
of this approach um doesn't seem to be
stopping them but even now
the main the leading immunologists in
the world that's what you agree with
what we have been saying for years
in the alternative medical field that
the immune system is not misguided
and that all of the immunity is born in
the gut i'm absolutely convinced of it
every autoimmune disease no matter how
far away from the
digestive system it develops might be
rheumatoid arthritis it might be
multiple sclerosis it might be diabetes
type one might be lupus might be
psoriasis might be neutropathy the roots
of that disease are in the gut
why because about 85 percent of your
immune system
is located in the gut wall so your
digestive system is the biggest
and the most important immune organ in
your body
this is where the immune system is being
fed is being looked after
and being properly informed because
about 90 percent of all cells in your
body leaving your gut flora
90 it means your body is only 10
it's a shell a habitat for this massive
microbes that live inside us
and these 90 of us interact with 85
percent of your immune system all the
time
they they work together like two parents
so when the
the the gut flow is abnormal in a person
when the person has
gaps patients psychology government
physiology syndrome
the immune system becomes unbalanced it
becomes malnourished it becomes
intoxicated
and it has a huge workload
because the gut becomes a major source
of toxicity
in the body so that's where autoimmunity
comes from
and every autoimmune disease the
treatment must begin
from healing and sealing the gut wall
we need to rebuild the gut wall for the
person out of
quality we need to close all those holes
and once those holes close up that river
of toxicity stops
it turns into a trickle into a little
stream and eventually it stops
and once that stops then everything in
the body can be cleaned up
re-balanced repaired as long as this
river toxicity keeps gushing in
nothing can be repaired in the pot you
will continue developing symptoms and
you will continue
um getting ill that is what we do with
the gaps nutritional protocol
we rebuild the gut wool for the person
we heal and seal the gut wall
we close all those holes we change
rebalance normalize the gut flora in the
person
that vital microbial community inside
the gut
there's nothing sterile in the human
body majority of your body are microbes
so we have to forget the idea that we
should be killing microbes or
sterilizing anything
the more microbes the merrier the bigger
the diversity of the better
all we need to do is rebalance it bring
it all
in the right appropriate balance and
that's what we do with the gaps
nutritional protocol
yeah wow that's exactly what's happened
to me throughout my life
as i was born and i was ill right away
and i was put on immune suppressants and
my disease continued to get worse
even though all the swelling went away
so that's exactly what happened and
i started eliminating foods just out of
curiosity
and i ended up on an all-meat diet so
just beef
and beef seemed to be the only thing
that wasn't triggering my immune system
so my theory was okay i stay on this for
a while
maybe the leaky gut will stop
and then i have to figure out how to fix
the microbiome issue
so what's the first stage of gaps that
you suggest how do you heal
all those holes like what is somebody
who's had generations of antibiotics
what is somebody like that supposed to
do the good news is that all cells in
the human body live a short life
they work very hard they get old worn
out
they die and they get replaced by newly
born cells
this wonderful process is called cell
regeneration and it's very active
in all of our tissues everywhere every
three months you've got a new liver
all your liver cells have died and got
replaced by newly born
liver cells and in the gut wall
our gut wall uh those cells only for two
or three days
the cell regeneration cell turnover
process that is extremely rapid
in order for the human body to give
birth to trillions of new cells
new baby cells every day building
materials are required
quality building materials and that is
what we provide in the gaps diet
the core of gas nutritional protocol is
the gaps diet
it's the most important thing if you
take water
out of the human body about 70 of the
human body's water
if we take that water out what we're
left with in the dry weight
50 50 protein and fat
when we analyze that protein in the
laboratory we find that it's very
similar to proteins in
meat fish eggs and dairy
animal foods plant proteins are
completely unsuitable for building our
protein
their amino acid composition is wrong
certain amino acids are missing and
amino acids are in excess
and they're indigestible for the human
digestive system
plant proteins p proteins soy protein
and all sorts of other proteins
in fact they are very damaging for the
digestive system of the human
and for all other tissues in the body
the same with fats when we take the
human fat and analyze it in the
laboratory
we find that in its biochemical
structure it's very similar to fats
which come from
lamb pork beef goose
plants are full of oils but thereby
chemical structure is very different
and completely unsuitable for human
physiology for building
our parts we need some
omega-3 omega-6 omega-7 some
polyunsaturated fatty acids but we need
the tiniest minute amount per day
just having a little salad having an
apple having a handful of nuts is enough
you will get enough of those oils
unfortunately majority of people in the
world are gorging on the
industrially processed plant oils
vegetable and cooking oils
these are poisons there are hundreds and
hundreds of scientific studies which
have been shown
uh conclusively uh that they cause every
chronic disease
under the sun mental illness infertility
heart disease diabetes obesity
alzheimer's disease all kinds of
illnesses nobody
should be eating these things and nobody
should be cooking on these things and
unfortunately all processed foods
in our supermarkets are made with these
oils so all processed foods have to be
out
for any person who's trying to recover
or maintain their health
so the only thoughts that are suitable
for the human physiology to consume
our animal fats and what i found through
my clinical experience
is that the more the merrier the more
animal fat a person manages to eat per
day the quicker they recover
there's no doubt about it so
in these animal foods that are the key i
have many patients in my clinic
since i've written the first gaps book
for those years i learned something
new every day for my patients because my
patients are my teachers
that's where i derive all the
information that i give to people i
haven't got this information from any
book
my my patients taught me all this and i
have these children
in whom uh with all sorts of colitis
with autism
and people with mental illness severe
mental illness
and people with rheumatoid arthritis and
people with some other
severe autism illnesses and also babies
with f
bias this is the new group of babies
with food-induced protein enterocolitis
syndrome these are little things which
cannot digest
any protein in the world at all even
mother's milk
makes them oh my gosh they're very very
damaged to these babies
so when i started working with these
very severe
patients and patients are getting more
and more severe
in the western world particularly in the
english-speaking countries
i don't know what's happening but our
children are getting antibiotic use
and sugar not just antibiotics the whole
environment the whole environment that
we created is unsuitable
for our children to come into this world
so what i found in these patients that
even the first stage of the gaps
introduction diet
because in the first jack's book i have
described two forms
of gaps diet the full gaps diet
which is easy to follow it has a wider
choice foods
and the gas introduction diet which is
structured in six
stages and that is the diet which heals
and seals your gut wall very effectively
and quite quickly
but it's more difficult to follow it's
very restrictive
so on the first stage of the gaps
introduction diet we start with foods
which are the easiest to digest and
which provide the biggest amount of
building materials for your gut wall
to produce those trillions of new baby
cells out of quality materials
healthy robust you know rosy cheeks
bushy tailed
cells and you've got learning so what we
do with the gaps introduction that we
build a new
gut wall for the person because human
body doesn't waste time on healing a
sick
cell if a cell is sick it's killed and
removed
and a new baby's cell is born in its
place
i know that you give birth to them we
need quality materials if we want
quality of that wall
and the quality materials come from
animal foods
so on the first stage of the gaps
introduction diet
we eat a lot of meat stock everything is
homemade everything is made out of fresh
best quality ingredients gelatinous
stalks
lots of collagen in the stock we make it
from collagenous gelatinous tissues
in we eat a lot of organs we eat a lot
of fermented
foods particularly fermented dairy and
we eat only cooked
vegetables in the limited amount low
fiber vegetables
nothing raw no raw plant matter and we
start with small amounts of vegetables
because plants are difficult for humans
to digest and they damage the human
digestive system
particularly the sensitive human
digestive system
the easiest things to digest for humans
are animal foods
that's the fact a clinical fact no
matter what the science might be
shouting from the newspapers and tv
screens that you whoever's paying for
that science
so yeah so what what happens
i found this group of patients with whom
even the first
stage of the introduction diet wasn't
gentle enough
yeah that would be me so we started
removing plant matter
because i knew through experience
through clinical experience that plants
are the problem
so we started removing all the
vegetables bit by bit and we finished up
with no
plants at all i have called this form a
no
plant gap style these patients label
meat stock
on cooked meats on fish on fermented
dairy products
on animal fats and
eggs that's it not a leaf not a speck
from a plant kingdom is consumed
and only when we've done that this
patient started recovering
they recover they come from ulcerative
colitis from crohn's disease they come
off medication
the inflammatory molecules disappear
everything becomes normal
they recover from learning disabilities
and mental illness
f5 children start growing and start
developing and start recovering from
this terrible situation
these are babies you know these children
so
i found it extremely successful and i
have quite a few patients who have been
on this diet now for
many years four five six years and they
have no intention of introducing any
plants
and they look beautiful and they're
healthy some people ask me
where do they get vitamin c clearly we
don't know everything about vitamin c
yet yeah now we know in the latest
research that organ needs
uh quite a good source of vitamin c in
the human body
as well as folate only be immediate
immunes and fat soluble vitamins and
other things
so these people show no signs of any
kind of nutritional deficiencies
so it is these patients who taught me
that human beings can live without
plants perfectly well
but we cannot live without animal foods
that is an absolute fact
i'd like to sort of move move into a
little um
sideline here i had anorexia girls many
anorexia girls coming into my clinic
um and young people with bipolar
disorder and psychosis and all sorts of
problems
and quite quickly i've discovered that
they became ill to such a degree
because of misguided veganism and
vegetarianism
we live in a world of nutritional
misinformation
and they push the propaganda for
vegetarians for plant-based lifestyle is
very strong at the moment
yeah these people are given an idea that
it is
morally right and it's healthy and it's
saving the planet
this sort of thing so these patients
forced me to look into this direction
start researching it
and very quickly what i've discovered
that there are no scientific studies
that we can trust in this area
every study has been conducted by
pro-vegetarian
lobby and they just incorrectly designed
incorrectly analyzed
they just lie particularly the chinese
study
that is the biggest lie yeah yeah in the
world
absolutely so having discovered that
fact that there is no science i could
rely upon
i went back to basic sciences the
science of physiology zoology biology
biochemistry and clinical experience
my own clinical experience and clinical
studies of my colleagues
of other holistic doctors and based on
that knowledge
um based on all that information i have
written a book called vegetarianism
explained which came out three years ago
now
where i explain that the animal foods
and only animal foods feed and build the
human body
they are the feeding building foods
because of the structure of the human
digestive system
the way our digestive system has been
designed we can only
truly properly digest animal foods
plants are indigestible for humans
for the human digestive system and they
do not
feed this and they provide their own
protein and wrong fats
for building our physical structure they
cannot build or feed your physical
structure
your heavy bones your heavy muscles your
big brain your big lungs big level
your big heart only animal foods can
maintain
and build your physical structure
properly prepared animal foods
traditional cultures around the world
have known this for millionaire
this fact that is why they will put the
biggest effort in into catching an
animal
catching fish getting meat getting eggs
getting milk
and they would use plants only as a
supplement
to meat and even then through experience
they have learned that plants are
indigestible
all plants are in their particularly
seeds of plants
and that is grains beans nuts all sorts
of seeds
it's particularly indigestible they're
full of chemicals called anti nutrients
which damage our digestive system damage
our collagen
damage all other tissues in the human
body so they've learned that they must
prepare the plants properly
before consuming them before even
cooking them
so they've developed methods of
fermentation sprouting
malting and cooking plants in such a way
to make them more digestible more
nutritious
for us more acceptable for the human
digestive system
to derive some nutrition from so having
discovered all of that
that is what i explain in the book
veganism
purely plant-based regimen is not a diet
it is a form of fasting
it has been considered a form of fasting
for tens of thousands of years in the
hindu culture in india
and they call it the fast and they will
never do it longer than 41 day or 42
days
veganism where you live purely entirely
on plants
when you start eating uh plants only
plants purpose of uh for the human
beings
is cleansing plants cannot feed the
human body to any degree
but they are powerful cleanses they have
powerful chemicals in them which keep
our bodies clean
on the inside they have phenols
salicylates
phytonutrients and various other
cleansing
substances and that is the purpose of
eating plants of keeping our bodies
clean
on the inside so uh when
people who are very toxic people who are
overweight who go on the vegan regimen
in the first few weeks as they start
cleansing a cleaner body feels better
than a toxic one
so many symptoms start disappearing they
start feeling better and this is the
time when they write the evangelical
books
about veganism but at certain point the
human body will finish cleansing
and it will need feeding it will become
hungry
and it will give you a signal i'm hungry
now feed me
the way it will give you that signal is
it'll give you a desire
for a roast chicken for bacon for fried
eggs for a piece of meat
or a pot of cream or something like that
problem is many legals in our own world
doing this for emotional reasons
political reasons
religious and other reasons so they
don't listen to their body
they override that signal and they
continue
um force their body to continue fasting
to continue cleansing and at that point
the body has no choice
but you start breaking down less
important tissues muscle and bone
to feed more important toxins your brain
your lungs your heart your liver your
digestive system
so the person starts losing muscle mass
starts losing a bone mass
and eventually starts developing
degenerative disease and i have seen far
too many
young people like that so um we've sort
of moved away from gallups a little bit
but if you know anyone who believes
uh in the plant-based lifestyle please
give them a book vegetarianism explained
making an informed decision you might
save the life
so coming back to the gaps nutritional
protocol
not only the brain is affected but every
organ every tissue in the body
is affected and that is what i described
in the new book gathering physiology
syndrome
which is coming out this autumn but i
will describe the full list of
autoimmune illnesses
atopi allergies asthma eczema and there
is other
allergy conditions fibromyalgia chronic
fatigue syndrome neurological illnesses
hormone illnesses and all sorts of other
illnesses
have you had many patients intolerant to
fermented dairy at the beginning yes
yes a lot of people when your gut wall
is damaged and porous and leaky
um there is a problem with dairy
in the world and the biggest problem is
that they've got the wrong cows
okay yeah right about that's right
that's the biggest problem
in the 60s and 70s our industrial
agriculture wasn't happy
with how much milk a normal cow is able
to
give them they wanted more profit so
they gave
an order to the scientists to produce a
cow that can give us more milk
so what the scientists did they took
animals which had a
brain tumor in their hypothesis which
was
producing growing hormone this was sick
animals
it had too much growth hormones when a
cow has too much growth hormones in her
body
she produces more milk she gives you
more milk
and from these sick animals they bred a
new variety of cows
commercial breeds of cows hosting
fashion huge huge beasts
which give us three times more milk than
a normal natural cow
is able to produce these are
frankenstein animals
they are sick from the beginning they
have about a third of normal cow's life
by the age of four they have cancer by
the age of three they will suffer from
arthritis and infertility
how can a sick animal give you healthy
milk
a sick animal will give you sick milk
these are frankensteins and you get your
frankenstein milk from it
and then our scientists you know in
other branches of science have produced
all this research to show us
that milk causes every disease under the
sun
cancer fertility heart disease to mental
illnesses and
everything else and all of that research
has been done with frankenstein milk
most milk in our supermarkets and most
dairy coming from the
food industry are from these cows they
are frankenstein
dairy of course they will make you sick
of course so number one thing to do with
the dairy you find
natural breeds of animals that mother
nature create
native breeds of animal whether it's a
goat or a cow
or a you or whatever it is whatever
animal that's the first thing
second thing all natural herbivorous
animals
cows goats sheep donkeys deer camels
they are pure herbivores they must live
on pasture
they must eat grass and they must not
eat grain
a little bit of properly prepared grain
fermented or sprouted is okay to feature
a dairy herd to sustain them a little
bit more because they're giving a lot
through the milk jersey cows for example
but that needs to be properly prepared
but
but 90 percent or more than 90 percent
of bulk
of what the cow eats must be from
pasture must be grass from pasture
hay helix and grass so that's what this
chaos must be and the pasture must be
organic
but there is a pleasure a variety a
diversity of plants growing together in
a community
because cows derive different nutrition
from different grasses
from different herbs and it's also
important for them to get access to some
bushes to some trees because they get
different nutrition from trees and
bushes
and other vegetation so that's the most
important thing
so if the cow is locked up in a cafe
confined animal factory operation
where she lives on standing in her own
excrements
and eats grain and soil all day long
the quality of her milk is not going to
be what mother nature intended for us
that will be sick milk coming from a
sick unhappy animal
so it needs to be first of all native
breed secondly on organic natural
diverse posture
not the kind of pasture that uh
industrial agriculture provides some of
them say oh i'll cows are in posture
what kind of posture it's a mono mono
culture of
a hybrid grass that they spray with
fertilizer
several times a year then they cut it
and they haul attention to kafal and
they feed that grass to the cows and
they call them grass-fed
the scales still never see the light of
day they never see the sun
they never put their hooves on pasture
they're still on concrete
somewhere but they're eating this hybrid
spray
dirty grass you know um are not a
natural a lot of it is genetically
modified too
that is not grass-fed that is not the
kind of milk we want
from from the animals okay once you have
a real animal another
on a real pasture that milk must not be
pasteurized
the cows need to be melted in hygienic
conditions so that doesn't get
contaminated after it leaves the animal
and it must not be pasteurized because
milk of any animal
is alive it's the white blood of the
female including humans
if we started pasteurizing human milk
before we give it to our babies our
babies would die
in a matter of weeks they would not live
because what is
milk coming from the woman to the baby
from the couch or her calf
it's her white blood it's got a life and
active immune cells
white blood cells active hormones
neurotransmitters
microbes because the blood is a
microbial community there's lots of
microbes in there and they're essential
this is a probiotic food
that comes in sugar into the baby when
we pasteurize milk we kill it
we kill all those cells we destroy the
structure of all those
hormones proteins active enzymes and so
on a good example is lactose
many people are lactose intolerant if
you drink raw milk the raw milk contains
an enzyme called lactase
to digest all the lactose in that milk
for you
when we pasteurize that milk the lactase
gets destroyed
so as a result there's nothing to digest
lactose
for you you become lactose intolerant
i've had so many patients i've lost
count
who lost their lactose intolerance when
they switched to drinking
wow yeah that's what i've heard
the aryan dairy and and we need to
understand that
problem is if you've been consuming
dairy from the supermarkets commercial
dairy
it takes about six months for all the
debris
of that dairy to leave your body so you
might have about six months period of
time
of cleansing from the dairy and
once it's left your body then you can
introduce proper
dairy proper natural raw organic and we
always introduced in the form of
in the fermented form always and in that
state in my experience
vast majority of people tolerated
perfectly well and it brings them over
to benefit
interesting okay so i've been on i told
you i've been on an all beef diet and
it's been
almost three years and that was because
i couldn't tolerate anything else
including
i couldn't take any pills like i
couldn't take anything without having a
flare-up
and i've been a proponent of telling
people to cut out dairy because it made
me
so ill and i've had lots of people reach
out and say you have to try raw dairy
because that that can heal you but i've
been worried because
i had such a terrible reaction to dairy
but your first step for people
if they're very damaged is seal the gut
by
consuming animal protein and fat and
then
why why should they reintroduce plants
if they can survive like that
is their benefit because plants bring
diversity
into the diet they bring variety they
bring color they bring different tastes
they just bring more enjoyment there's
just pleasure just
from eating pleasure exactly it's
pleasurable
and if they're properly prepared then
it gives variety it makes your social
life a little bit more interesting
yeah and it brings variety into your
diet and the rights of nutrition for you
but your gut needs to be strong enough
to digest them
i describe the no plant gaps diet in
detail
in the new book that is coming out oh
that is so cool
okay so these people who heal their gut
they're like strict with what they eat
they heal their gut
their first step is microbial diversity
how do you
fix imbalances is that just with the
fermented dairy
so through consumption of fermented
foods
consumption of fermented foods and
consumption of
the foods properly prepared and
meat stocks is extremely important we
make meat stop not bone broth
we do not start with bone broth there is
a difference between the two
i will never start with bone broth in
the gaps diet
in the new book and in the first gaps
book i have a whole uh
section on how to introduce dairy safely
for people who react
to dairy it's called a dairy
introduction structure you will
find it there all the guides all the
guidelines on how to introduce it
and in in this book i'd explain how to
prepare the foods properly
we always have meat stock that is an
absolute staple
of the gabstead because they need stock
when they make it properly from the
proper parts of the animal
they provide all the building materials
to build a new gut wall for you
new collagen new connective tissue new
joints new ligaments new bones
new muscles new blood vessels new nerves
everything you rebuild your body because
all of your body
renews itself all the time and we build
it out of
new quality materials so you finish up
after a few years you finish up with a
completely different body
not the one you had before yeah so how
long
for people who are really ill is there a
certain amount of time that you've seen
that they have to stay on
this meat stock diet before they can
start varying
their diet it's not just meat stock no
way it needs stock with a lot of organs
organs are absolutely vital to eat wheat
meats
with fat we fenced dairy with eggs
and wheat fish as well we eat fish and
shellfish
so it's it's quite a big variety and on
the uh
if if plants are tolerated for the
person we eat a lot of plants too
properly prepared we start with
vegetables non-starch starch is an
absolute enemy
for majority of chronic conditions so
non-starch
vegetables so um starting the gaps diet
and you will find that
it's very varied and it's actually quite
an easy
nourishing and delicious diet you follow
and you don't have to be cooking all the
time
because you can't cook large amounts
cook in bulk have leftovers
so you have a choice of leftovers in the
fridge for yourself to warm up
whenever you're hungry so different
people how long
different people take different time if
we just dealing with ibs let's say
with irritable bowel syndrome six months
a year the person is off they can start
coming off the gaps there they've healed
their gut
they're fine but if we're dealing with
rheumatoid arthritis or multiple
sclerosis
or fibromyalgia or schizophrenia or
something very very severe and very
serious
then the gaps that has to be for life
once you're on the full gaps diet you
have a very wide range of foods that are
available to you
all the vegetables are available you can
eat fruit you can eat all the berries
you can eat all the animal foods
you eat a lot of fermented foods healing
happens in stages
bit by bit you eventually you reach a
level where you can
maintain your health and you are healthy
and well and beautiful
for the rest of your life as long as you
adhere to that and
a lot of these people when they go on
holiday or when they're
at the party or they visit in france
they can
eat whatever they want occasionally your
body can understand
cheating coming off the bed you can come
off it for a few days or even for a
couple of weeks
but then when you come home you go back
to your normal
to maintain your health and your body
will let you know whether it's ready for
these transgressions on heart
so you don't have to go to a party and
start explaining to everything oh i
can't eat this and i can't do that you
can just eat what you want
whatever's there you know you can enjoy
yourself um
but then listen to your body for the
next few days it will let you know
whether that was acceptable or not and
at certain point
um it would be acceptable you will find
that you can understand these things and
you're fine
okay have you seen people have trouble
with eggs at the beginning
yes there are allergies to all kinds of
foods people can
have but what we do the only allergies
that we respect in the gaps nutritional
protocol
are anaphylactic typologies because
they're dangerous
and efficient it's when your mouth
swells and your
breathing passages swell you can't
breathe and it's it's life-threatening
all other allergies they ignore unless
they're extremely dramatic and
very problematic because all other
allergies
including antiphalaxicologists are
caused by the fact that your gut wall is
like a sieve
it's got right big holes in it and food
absorbs undigested
once we heal and seal the gut wall food
starts absorbing properly digested and
all these allergies disappear
one by one i have many patients in whom
even anaphylactic type allergies have
disappeared
when the first few patients we found
that out by accident
when something happened the person
consumed something by mistake
and there was no reaction so we started
testing looking at that
and even anaphylaxiologists get
cancelled out
by the when the gut will properly healed
so we ignore all these salvages and
we'll focus on healing and sealing the
gut world building a new
gut wall for the person and at certain
point all the sandwiches disappear one
by one
of course if you have one particular
food that is causing you the biggest
trouble
it's sensible to remove it for a period
of time
but um many people go to laboratories
start testing
for food allergies and intolerances get
this list of foods you know four pluses
for this three pluses for that
two glasses start removing foods out and
they remove and remove and finish up
with
virtually nothing left to eat and
they're still reacting
because as long as your gut is like a
serve you're absorbing everything you
eat and digest it
and your reaction to it everything so
ignore the testing i don't even
recommend these tests
at the beginning of the protocol i
recommend you focus on the introduction
diet to heal and seal your gut will
then okay a few months later your body
will let you know now
99 of these foods i used to react to i'm
not reacting to any more i'm fine with
that but this one
that i'm still still problematic so at
that point you can
uh remove that food for a while wait
maybe three four months and then try it
again and see what happens
so your your assumption for people who
start on the
like first gaps diet and who say are
reacting to
eggs or something is that eggs aren't
actually damaging their gut
but at that moment it's leaking through
and your body is reacting to it so you
just have to wait
they're coming in slightly undigested
that is why the symptoms
people majority of people react to the
white egg white
yeah so it's uh that is why in the
introduction that we just start with raw
egg yolks
you should remove the whites and in my
experience
vast majority of people do not react to
the egg yolk
that they tolerated perfectly well it is
a wonderful source of nutrition
raw egg yolk so i would keep it in the
diet as much as possible
unless there is of course type allergy
yeah i'm gonna say that's the only
energy we respect
wow so just i think the last question i
have before i wrap
up is you you started this diet quite a
while ago
and there must have been a huge kickback
against what you were saying especially
what
all autoimmune disorders are caused by
one thing
people can survive on only animal foods
like
what was that like did you receive a lot
of criticism
i haven't actually because i haven't
been
fighting anyone i haven't when i
discovered the concept of gaps
i knew instinctively immediately that
the last people i should give this
information to
are the medical profession
the last people because i knew that they
will
stole me from this idea
so i didn't do that i gave this
information to people who needed it
badly in the world
i gave it to my patients and i gave it
to the parents of children with learning
disabilities
because i initially started working with
autism and then
other children with hyperactivity
dyslexia dyspraxia other problems
started coming in and then children with
allergies and then diabetes type one and
then adults
with all sorts of problems and that's
how the whole thing is now
and i just gave this information to
people who needed this information
badly and because i was dealing with
nutrition
diet somehow it's outside the realms of
the mainstream medicine
major medicine is not interested in that
so i actually was
surprisingly not attacked and uh left
alone
and i think the majority of mainstream
medicine is still blissfully unaware
that this
these diseases can be cured yes
yeah otherwise a lot of people would be
out of jobs
yeah well thank you very much for coming
on all that information is absolutely
fascinating and that's exactly
what i've experienced with my diet is
couldn't tolerate anything
i slowly healed just eating meat and now
i seem to be able to tolerate
a few things but i'll probably take into
consideration the raw
dairy try that out it was just like my
autoimmune responses were so terrible i
had psychological problems as well that
the reactions were scary enough that i
was like
found a diet and it works i'll just
stick with this you're
beautiful now thank you you're looking
healthy and beautiful
thank you very much and thank you again
for coming on
is there anywhere i can direct listeners
i have a website called gaps.me
me i have a blog which you can find off
the website
i have been training medical
practitioners for
about 10 years now and we have thousands
of
gaps certified practitioners around the
world we now put the training
online so you can find the training
courses on
gapstraining.com gapstraining.com
so that is for qualified medical
practitioners health practitioners
and also for not qualified people
because we now have several courses
for different levels of qualifications
for people
who want your help so you're welcome to
have a look there and see if you would
like to get trained
great great well thank you very much
again that's a pleasure thank you for
inviting me
[Music]
you